last year's Best Supporting Actor for
Million Dollar Baby
and a penguins desperate Academy Award
winner Morgan Freeman
we had faces then as the heroine of
Sunset Boulevard famously remarked and
describing the birth of the movies well
we have faces now and the five warm
beautiful intelligent expressive and
demonstrative faces demonstrative faces
of these five women filled this year's
screens with joy here are the nominees
for the best supporting actress Amy
Adams in junebug Catherine Keener in
Capote
Frances McDormand in North Country
rachel weisz in the Constant Gardener
Michelle Williams in Brokeback Mountain
and the Oscar goes to
Rachel Weisz the custom gardener this is
the first Academy Award for Rachel Weisz
number audiences for her lead role in
the mummy and The Mummy Returns
so much to the Academy for this
tremendous tremendous honor I share it
with others ray finds my my luminous
acting partner
Fernando Morales our director who's
brimming over with such humanity and our
dignified sensitive producer Simon
Channing Williams and of course john
lecarre a who who wrote this this
unflinching angry story and and he
really paid tribute to to the people who
are willing to risk their own lives to
fight injustice and their their greater
men and women than i but thank you thank
you so much thank you